si usted o alguien que conoce padecen de
presión arterial alta este vídeo le
mostrará algunas maneras de manejarla
en la mayoría de los casos se desconoce
la causa de la presión arterial alta o
hipertensión este tipo de presión
arterial alta se denomina primaria o
hipertensión esencial
el tratamiento incluye cambios en el
estilo de vida como una alimentación
saludable
si usted es sensible al sodio en la sal
el médico puede recomendar que consuma
menos sal y alimentos procesados el
sodio puede hacer que el cuerpo retenga
agua esto incrementa la cantidad de su
sangre y hace que se incremente la
presión arterial
hay otros cambios en el estilo de vida
que pueden disminuir la presión arterial
estos incluyen no beber demasiado
alcohol
ejercitarse regularmente
y perder peso si es necesario
y dejar de fumar
y su médico puede también recomendar
medicamentos que actúan sobre los
riñones
y vasos sanguíneos
o corazón para ayudar a reducir la
presión arterial
los diuréticos comúnmente denominado
píldoras de agua hacen que los riñones
se eliminen más sal y agua de la sangre
a través de la orina esto reduce la
cantidad de sangre y la presión arterial
y los bloqueadores beta reducen la carga
de trabajo en el corazón de dos maneras
disminuyen los latidos y la fuerza de
cada latido
los diversos tipos de medicamentos
reducen la presión arterial relajando
sus vasos sanguíneos esto hace que se
abran aún más
estos medicamentos incluyen inhibidores
ace
bloqueadores receptores 2 angiotensina
bloqueadores del canal de calcio
y vasodilatadores de actuación directa
es importante seguir tomando los
medicamentos siguiendo las instrucciones
aun si ya se siente mejor no deje de
tomar los medicamentos a menos que se lo
indique su médico si tiene preguntas
acerca de cualquier medicamento que le
hayan recetado consulte con su médico